un autre moment d'anthologie quand même
thomas pesquet bien sûr qu'ils fans de
kaamelott et qui a pu visionner le film
en avant première depuis les ss avec ses
amis vous êtes aussi fasciné par
l'univers du coup les choses se
rejoignent à ce moment là la boucle est
bouclée en quelque sorte sauf quand vous
ratez son appel et la catastrophe se
fout dans mais depuis vous êtes parler
thomas pesquet a atterri dit ouais non
c'est pas eux non mais seul le truc est
réglé bien entendu mais je veux dire il
ya quand même un truc
parce que moi je j'ai fini par devenir
mal peu je sais pas vous moi j'ai fini
par devenir malpolis avec les gens qui
appellent sur votre téléphone pour
essayer de vous vendre de l'énergie aux
assurances ou des machins qui ont votre
numéro perso et moi je sais pas parce
que chez j'ai lu j'ai plein de gamins
j'ai toujours peur qui est que qui a un
gars qui disent merde il eu un accident
faut que j'appelle un truc donc je
réponds quand même parce que je sais pas
ce qui arrive souvent et puis bon jour
je vous propose machin et j'avoue j'ai
fini par envoyer chier maintenant je
suis un mec police je suis gentil et
tout mais là maintenant j'envoie chier
je peux plus je suis peu plus çà et là
c'était un numéro du texas jeudi normes
et les mecs sont ils se font passer pour
derrick pour aller me vendre je sais pas
quelle connerie encore ils s'arrêteront
jamais quoi et puis j'ai un message
vocal et à vous avez un message vocal de
m
j'ai un message vocal du gars qui me dit
ouais je sais c'est un numéro un peu
bizarre mais c'est dommage les gens des
fois répondent pas je suis dans les ss
là
je vais être remercié bon bah salue
enfin bon j'ai un message vocal de
l'espace non mon téléphone je les
gardais sas archives bien entendu